Now, we have our general form of the confidence interval. So, for some y
percent confidence interval, this could be 95%, 99%, anything really. Usually,
it's somewhere in the 90s. Then, the lower bound of the confidence interval is
the sample mean minus the number of standard deviations away from the mean.
Where this z value is the number of standard deviations and sigma divided by
the square root of n is the standard deviation of the sampling distributions.
And then, on the upper bound, we just add the number of standard deviations
away that we want. If we have a 95% confidence interval, we'll have less
standard deviations away than we will for a 98% confidence interval. Remember
that we get this z-value from the z-table. So, if this is a 98% confidence
interval let's say, then we'll have 1% in the tails. And then, we'd look for
the z-score for which 1% is less in a standard normal distribution. The
distance that we go away from x-bar, on either side, is the margin of error.
And as you can see, that's equal to z times sigma divided by root end. And
that's half the width of the confidence interval.